I had the idea on a Sunday evening I
posted in slack about a dozen people
reply we had a call Monday afternoon and
by that Friday the first version of our
website was live
you
you're aware that you're like living
through this enormous li important
little bit and I really wanted to help
having a good spirit and like a bad
moment is something that's very
infectious I just felt really deeply
called to action in some way to do
something a group of us sitting around
our dining room table thinking about you
like doing something meaningful and
impactful time just translates to lives
it's just like a battle against time so
in mid-march I posted one little thing
on slap started this whatsapp group
here's the Google form like sign ups
there were over a hundred responses and
so this idea for a gift card Bank came
to me oh my gosh my my we make them
behind sorry
of course then things escalated so
quickly it just started from there and
on the day when we were talking we built
our website our platform within like two
or three hours when I got the call it
was it was like a no-brainer GSB it's
about changing organizations a world on
a bigger scale why can we do it work
till like 2:00 3:00 4:00 a.m. but
everybody throughout the process I think
was just really excited trying to figure
out how to connect resources to people
who need them
we called them we asked them what they
needed what their challenges were and
then we the number of MBA students I
volunteered their time was like so
inspiring been inspired by how quickly
people
I think this moment has made it
abundantly clear that it doesn't take a
lot to like throw it out there to like
to make other people feel a little bit
better if it keeps growing which is
awesome it makes the effort feel worth
it so busy GSP Network has been helping
us throughout the world China and beyond
China they do have some crazy stories
which why should we talk about Tammy it
was just like so many you're just like
floored by the capacity to innovate it's
definitely a community effort to figure
out ways to give back right now so it's
been an exercise and seeing all the good
in the world and trying to add in and
give people a sense of hope and also out
of the lifeline
[Music]
you